i've always been of that view but
independent adjudication of that is
important
to me but it's also important to the
scottish public
to know that in the opinion of somebody
whose independence is completely beyond
reproach
i did not breach the ministerial quote
so i'm delighted and of course relieved
about that
yeah i wonder if you perhaps had breed a
big sigh of relief what was your
immediate reaction when you
saw the conclusions of this report well
obviously relieved i mean
some you know pretty grim allegations
have been
leveled at me over at the past months
they've
not been easy they've been difficult to
contend with i have been
at peace with my own conscience on all
of these matters i
have been very clear in my own mind that
i acted appropriately and did not breach
the ministerial code but
that while that might be necessary is
not sufficient it's important to the
scottish people that they have
independent verification and
adjudication of that and that of course
is
what they now have when you consider the
very high standard that you
set for yourself when you introduce the
ministerial code have you really
when you examine it closely lived up to
the spirit as well as the letter of this
code yes i believe i have
but more importantly so does somebody
whose independence
is beyond doubt james hamilton has
looked at all of the allegations that
were made
about me in respect of the ministerial
code and on each and every one of them
has
considered that i did not breach the
ministerial code i was confronted with
a very difficult situation i readily
accept i did so before the parliamentary
committee that
some people in being confronted with a
similar situation might have made
different judgments to the one
ones that i made but i believe i acted
appropriately in a difficult situation
and i'm pleased that i have the
independent verification of
of the doubt at some that he says it's
regrettable that you didn't give
a complete account of what you knew well
welcome to parliament for instance
and seems to have bought your
explanation because it wasn't
impossible that you might have forgotten
well i'm sorry if it's disappointing
that
the result wasn't different well you
know section 18 of that report is
unequivocal he says in terms that having
looked at all of that i think there's
four
key allegations were made against me in
relation to the ministerial code and
he's considered all of the
evidence he's considered all of the
material that was put to him and
unequivocally not on the one hand on the
other hand but unequivocally he says
i did not reach the ministerial code and
you know i think that is important and
i said i would accept the outcome of mr
hamilton's
inquiry and i think it is now incumbent
on others
to accept the outcome of it as well when
we
look at that key meeting you had with
alexander
of april 2018. are you clear that
whether that was a party meeting or a
government meeting because there was
always confusion glenn i
set this out in eight hours of evidence
to the parliamentary
uh inquiry and i think one of the things
that i take responsibility for was
allowing that
party government distinction to take on
more significance than it had
and i agreed to meet him on
the basis of party and personal
considerations you know clearly he then
came to me to talk about a government
inquiry but as i said out to the
committee
and as i have set out in other
ways the reasons i didn't then report
under the ministerial code was not to do
with that distinction it was to do and
james hamilton
agrees with this it was because for me
to report those meetings would have
compromised
the independence and the confidentiality
of the process
he says that it's for parliament to
decide whether or not
it was misled we know as a result of a
leak that
parliament at least the majority on the
committee conducting the separate
inquiry has decided
that you did mislead them what's your
response to that well
firstly james hamilton was given the
task of
determining whether or not i breached
the ministerial code and he's decided
that i did not breach the ministerial
code and one of the allegations
that he has reached that conclusion on
was whether or not i misled parliament
now
you know of course subjectively for
parliament to decide that but
you know i look forward if that's the
right expression to the committee report
being published uh
tomorrow we will look at that in great
detail
but i cannot escape the conclusion that
there are some members of that committee
because their public utterances show
this
that decided before a single word of
evidence had been taken that i was
guilty
of something and nothing was going to
remove them from that view
this is the independent report that has
concluded i did not mislead parliament
and i didn't reach the ministerial code
in any respect
some members of that committee and say
that the big part is that and
why shouldn't we consider that the sap
members who took your side
why why should we conclude that they're
being part of that well i'm
basically asking people to conclude that
somebody who has no political acts to
grind on either side
but is an independent lawyer who has
looked at this
independently has reached the
conclusions that he well in attacking
the the leaked conclusions of
the parliamentary committee i just want
you to be clear
is that to say that you will reject the
rest of their report or where they have
made unanimous
conclusions are you open to accept i
will look carefully at the committee i
notwithstanding uh the fact that i've
been cleared
of wrong wrongdoing and breaching the
ministerial code the scottish government
made a mistake in the handling of the
complaints
against alexander two women were let
down as a result of that and i take
that very seriously and i hope the
committee
um has things to say that will
contribute to a process
of learning lessons about that do you
accept and fool the findings of the dram
report which
uh requests uh suggests revisions to
your procedures for dealing with
complaints yeah
the deputy first minister said last week
that we will take forward the
recommendations
of the delop review and we will take the
time to make sure
that we get this right i am very very
conscious of the fact that there is a
process
to be undergone about rebuilding trust
and learning lessons from the mistake
that the scottish government made
i will continue to say that was a
mistake made in the course of the
government trying to do
the right thing in days gone by the
mistake wouldn't have happened because
complaints of this nature would have
been swept under the carpet so it's
important we learn those lessons
and have a situation where anybody who
feels that they have been subject to
harassment
by a minister past or present has the
confidence to come forward and know that
they will be listened to
are you confident that your special
advisors have acted properly throughout
politics
yes i am um and you know let's not
forget that serious
allegations have been made serious
allegations have been made about me
and the conclusion of an independent
report is that i was not
guilty of those allegations well this
inquiry
ponders whether special advisers should
come under the ministerial code and you
might have a
view on that but in looking at some of
the evidence hamilton
finds it credible that alexander's
former chief of staff
gave an account of a meeting with a
senior official in your
administration um where it was suggested
there had been a leak
of information um does that require
further investigation
well as i understand there is a
complaint that's been made about that
which will be taken
forward in the the proper way but let me
well let me be clear about this mr
hamilton has been asked to look at
um different accounts of meetings and
discussions
and he has assessed all of that but what
mr hamilton was being asked to
adjudicate on
taking all of that into account is
whether or not i've reached the
ministerial code
and he has been very clear and
unequivocal in his conclusion that i did
not
do you think there needs to be a police
inquiry into the leak
of the findings of the original
investigation into mr sanford he
suggested the police should get involved
with them
it was a leak from your government well
there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever to say it was a leak from
my government and well no i with the
greatest of respect
there is not evidence that it was a leak
from my government that was not
a leak from me to the very best of my
knowledge it was not
a leak from anybody around me and if mr
salmon
i would love to know where it came from
i know well look that's a matter for the
police
i'm first minister i don't instruct the
police in terms of what they do and do
not investigate as i think you probably
know
there's uh no confidence at hollywood in
you tomorrow do you have the votes
to see that through no we'll see
tomorrow i'm confident uh
that uh that vote uh will express
confidence
in me i i mean let's you know remember
here the tories
said they would have a vote of
confidence in me before i'd uttered a
single word of evidence before the
parliamentary inquiry they have decided
at this issue a long time ago so you
know that's a political stunt
being brought forward by the tories
tomorrow but can i say
this as well i'm confident in the
outcome of that vote tomorrow but the
day after tomorrow
this parliamentary term will come to a
conclusion
and it's now for voters to decide who
they want to be first minister
after this election i'll be putting
myself forward as
the candidate for first minister because
there's a big job of work to be done to
continue to lead this country
through a pandemic i believe i'm the
right person to do that and i want to
focus on these issues i've just come off
a call this afternoon with families
who've been bereaved as a result of
covet that's where my
focus and attention needs to lie and
that's where it will be lying